yeah but that that red-eye flight to
miami was rough yeah i mean you know i'm
glad we still did it because we got to
do the uh the ludwig barrier cart
tournament yeah yeah so
super fun we did the ludwig bureau car
which is mario kart double dash but you
can't drive um but you have to down a
beer you have to you can't drive
you can't drink and drive because that's
illegal and that's bad yeah but you have
to down your beer either before you
start driving or any point when you stop
if you do your caster completely stop
yeah so we really wanted to do this and
uh ludwig said that it would start 2 p.m
and our flight was at 3. there was no
way we could do it so we moved it to a 9
pm flight so we could make it right um
but that flight was brutal that was
horrible yeah because we got to miami at
i think it was like 5 00 or 6 a.m and
then we and that was the first day of
the convention as well so we had a
signing from 1 p.m that same day so we
got to luckily though the airport and
the hotel we were staying at were pretty
close it was like 15 20 minute driveway
uh so we just literally just got to
miami got to the hotel slept for as long
as we could and then immediately headed
to the con but that was still a chill
con i enjoyed that yeah miami was a
really cool place yeah i thought miami
was really beautiful um obviously i wish
i just wish we had more time to actually
kind of explore miami yeah yeah because
i was going to ask because i've never
been to florida before um like how was
florida in general did you meet florida
man did you meet luckily luckily not
luckily not people were more chill in
florida than l.a i think i feel like it
was um the food was really good
food the cuban restaurant was insane
human food is nutty my god we were
[ __ ] up we were so full so much
so much so much meat we had uh like
peruvian food another day and that was
really good yeah yeah approved that
hummus they made this was insane
remember that peruvian so did you only
stay there for the weekend of the
convention oh yeah yeah yeah we landed
on the the first day of the con and then
we left the morning of the day after
yeah it was good though i mean i i'd
like to go back to miami at some point
and just be a tourist yeah yeah but also
there's a lot of old people in miami i
didn't notice that yeah it wasn't as
young as i thought it would be but i
guess there's a lot of old people
retiring i guess yeah so i saw a lot of
60 year old looking men that were bronze
basically
with with uh with six year olds this
permanent team were bronze as well and i
was like
so is this is miami just a glorified
retirement home that's why all the
buildings are really bright it's so that
you can find the people
yeah no but miami was really fun it was
like too humid though oh it's like
japanese yeah yeah it was basically
japan don't talk to me about humidity
right now guys
it's basically what you're feeling here
is what it was like in my mind it was
too much it was pretty brutal yeah i
just wish i had enough time to like go
to the beach or you know even go to the
pool or anything but like i didn't even
have enough time to do that we were just
tired as well because we've been in l.a
for like a month we were in the uk
before so i think you're just dead we're
just so dead yeah yeah i was [ __ ]
well we did get the taste of la life
guys
how did you share it because we actually
i think
this so what we did was you were
currently in the la arc on trash taste
um and we what we did was we rented out
an airbnb and we used as a studio but
also it was kind of like our first
experience living with each other as
well
in terms of living with each other sorry
it's like a disney show
just a couple of friends
just filming some videos
what will they get up to yeah we
basically just made a trash taste house
you know because everyone in l.a thought
we already lived next to each other or
by each other uh and that wasn't the
case in japan [ __ ] we live actually
pretty far away from each other like
close enough that we can get to the
office but
not close enough where we could easily
make content with each other like
everyone else does in l.a games yeah we
just don't live together so yeah yeah
exactly exactly uh yeah and i i thought
it was a [ __ ] like a [ __ ] blast
honestly living with the boys it was
really really fun but i feel it was fun
because of the time limit that we had
right like if you told me you know no
offense to you boys but like this
applies i feel with anybody yeah right
that's not like your significant other
or whatever if you lived for long enough
with each other i feel like you're going
to be [ __ ] sick of each other and i
feel that's why a lot of content houses
just don't work out in the long run
right because it's like it's it's a
honeymoon period to begin with but then
the longer you're with together you're
like
yeah i kind of value my privacy as well
yeah
i might have my own room but it's not
quite the same
another thing i noticed as well is that
if we did have a trash taste house like
a trash taste content house i don't
think i'd get anything done no because
these boys are distractions like
normally normally i want to hang out
with you
normally i go i wake up go to my office
i'm like great work starting you know
catch up to emails or something this
time i go up go to the living room see
mailing or jerry up and i'm like oh what
are you what are you up to what are you
up to what do you just like have
breakfast and chat for about three hours
yeah just things just go slower because
you're talking to other people yeah yeah
so like whereas maybe i get lunch and i
eat in 10 minutes so i go right back to
work at my house yeah lunch becomes like
an hour and a half yeah yeah exactly
exactly it's good though i think cause
this is the first time i've gone to la
where i
went with the like express purpose of
trying to make like as much content as
possible
so it was really fun because i there was
like no days where i wasn't
uh doing hanging out with someone or
making something and so it was pretty
satisfying because i
but for me it's like
i i feel like i get my battery recharged
through making content yeah i'm [ __ ]
addicted to making like youtube videos
right here so like for me it's like if
i'm not doing that it's like oh i get
like i'm like oh i want to make
something yeah i want to film something
so it was like a whole month of just
being creative and getting to perform
and getting to go on stuff it was just
great you are you are truly a shining
beacon for content creators
like i i think people are like oh dude
i'm like no dude i [ __ ] love this
[ __ ] like this is what i'm addicted to
like i don't know why like i love being
on i love being on [ __ ] shows i love
doing events like yeah yeah it did
constantly like la did constantly feel
like you were filling up a progress bar
or like something in terms like content
or connections or projects or something
even if even if we weren't like actively
filming something every day but even so
i still felt like i was way more
distracted in la than
i would normally be at home yeah i feel
there were just like too many nights
especially when like most or all of us
were just like hanging out for the night
where i was just like i could be in my
room streaming or making content but i'd
rather just go out onto the balcony and
just chill with everyone yeah
there'd be so many times where i'm like
i could just set up a like we had like a
bare bones basic stream set up in one of
the rooms and i was like i got time to
stream but joey's out there chilling
maybe maybe i'll go chill with joey for
a bit and then i'll just have like a
quick five minute chat and then we'll go
stream and then seven hours later
and then the five minute chat turns into
like half an hour then we've got to get
lunch and then you know we're meeting
someone in like an hour so i'm like okay
i guess i can't stream you know yeah i
would
my main channel would be non-existent
yeah if we had a trash taste house i
feel yeah i can see why there are so
many streamer houses now because you
know living your life is just [ __ ]
content at that point pretty much uh and
if you if i had to like actively go out
and make the kind of content i do my
main channel that just wouldn't [ __ ]
happen if we had a trash taste house
yeah these boys are too much fun yeah
exactly it was very motivating though
yeah yeah i got very motivated oh yeah
definitely to make more stuff and push
push it i'll shout out to ludwig always
uh the inspiration yeah he was so nice
yeah i can love that guy yeah
i feel like he's my long-lost american
brother but i i we've been disconnected
from that i honestly feel most if not
all the like new and old faces we met up
in l.a were just like really really nice
people yeah in general you know and yeah
no it is true like i always get a
massive kick of inspiration out of like
hanging out with someone who perhaps
i've never met before but i know their
content or like you know some other
content creator i don't get to see or
talk too often and you know like
conventions for me are the same thing as
well just like you know being in a
convention setting which we were a lot
this past couple of months just like
it's like oh yeah this this is why i do
this like this is this is this is just
motivating me to like do better for
these people you know yeah um yeah no so
it's good i i mean you know i may not
have been necessarily motivated while we
were in la or while we were traveling
but after i came back to japan i had
like a [ __ ] list of ideas so you know
that's always good now sami i feel like
it's important for every content creator
to get their content battery recharged
and i feel like the best way to do that
is just to hang out with other people
hanging hanging out with other like
creative people because so many ideas
get thrown around and you're like damn
all right i can actually do this all
right i've got so many ideas now whereas
if you're just sitting in a room just
constantly pumping out content it kind
of like you just get into a grind and
you get into like it's monotonous yeah
it does get monotonous a lot of times
and you forget why you started doing
this in the first place and one thing i
would say about hanging out with so many
people in la so many other content
creators is that it definitely gets
those
creative juices flowing again yeah
absolutely yeah especially seeing some
of the like seeing the what motivates me
the most is seeing other people do
something exciting yeah because then i'm
like damn i want to do something yeah
this looks [ __ ] incredible exactly
exactly
and la is just like the central hub of
that
um but yeah aside from that there were
it was i mean did you guys enjoy your
experience in la overall oh yeah i
[ __ ] loved it yeah me personally yeah
i i enjoyed la i think because of the
people i got to see yeah if i if i
didn't get to see anyone and i was just
living in la
you know without ever interacting with
other content creators personally
no
yeah just because like i don't think the
la lifestyle necessarily meshes with me
yeah i i i [ __ ] hate the lifestyle
but when i was there i had like an
amazing time oh yeah yeah definitely um
and also i mean i i hate to admit it
there's some amazing food there oh no
the food's great oh that was food that
was some amazing amazing car i must have
ordered the porto's cubano sandwich like
a million [ __ ] times that that [ __ ]
went hard
in california nutty yeah yeah also joe
and the juice yeah yeah no so we have
during the juice in the uk right do we
we do okay and there's one in australia
as well it's this coffee [ __ ] chain
and like i don't really care for their
coffee but in in the one in america
they sold like this sandwich that's like
a spicy tuna sandwich and it was so
goddamn good me and joey must have eaten
it like five times i i think i ate it
like ten times i was so goddamn good
froth of the mouth every time i think
about that my comments go back i know i
just i want to go back just for that me
and joey we had had one in l.a yeah i
was like you have to try this tuna
sandwich i know i know you're going to
love it so he tries it like this is
insane yeah we pull up to our hotel in
miami
at the bottom of the hotel is a joe in
the literally the next thing over from
the hotel wasn't john there's just like
it's fate we're like fish bomb we're
like nice
so every morning we would just wake up
and be like coffee and chew spicy
sandwich i got you so good yeah so
[ __ ] good